thank you so I'm going to talk about
some recent work on nearly linear time
algorithms for maximum flow and
undirected graphs ok so first the
maximum flow problem is just so we're
given a graph has n vertices M edges the
edges are capacitated so for each edge
there's some capacity has the same
capacity in each direction and for each
vertex there's some demand bi or so bi
can be positive or negative if it's
negative you think of this as a supply
and so what we want is to find a flow
which is just an assignment from each
edge to some real number I can again be
positive or negative such that it
respects the capacities and at the net
flow into I is bi and i'm just going to
write that by bf equals B so that's so b
is just the matrix that map's flows to
excesses so this is a linear constraint
so I want to find a flow restructure the
quebec that respects the capacities and
such that the net flow into I is being
okay so alternatively this might not be
possible and the reason it might not be
possible well so for example if there
were two if there were a set such that
the total demand the aggregate demand so
that on this left this be I'm using this
notation BS to be the sum over all I and
as the BS but the total aggregate demand
in 2's if that were exceeds the total
aggregate capacity that's an S so i'm
using a notation cs4 that well then
clearly it's impossible to do we want
there's there's no way that we're going
to route we can't flow be s into s if
the capacity is less than that so we
want to so given our input data we want
to either find the flow or if it's
impossible you want to find this such a
cut and so the max the well the max-flow
min-cut theorem says that these two
cases are exhausted so either either
such a flow exists or a cut must exist
so in the case of an approximate
algorithm we're going to relax this
further to say well instead of having
the flow respect to capacities will
allow like a 1 plus epsilon
multiplicative error so alternatively
you can think of so what is the
justification for this well you could
also think of this as saying well if we
were to scale down our demands by 1 over
1 plus epsilon then we could we could
meet them so when you're going to
consider it an approximate problem no I
guess there's a couple things we've used
so first we could say BF is not exactly
equal to B that might be kind of useless
probably if you want to rattle flow you
probably want to write exactly the
demand so the natural thing to relax
does it say okay fine we can route the
demand but not as quickly in the sense
that we have to ski their scale down the
demand Ruby would exceed capacities so
we're going to still require that you
write exactly the demand we're just
going to allow a possible multiplet of
error on the passage
okay so there's this is a very well
stated problems with a long line of
history so I'm just going to talk about
the work that applies to basically the
most recent work up until up until this
so for a while the best-known result was
as a result of goldberg and rao that
actually worked in directed graphs and
got a running time with em to the three
halves and then in doesn't end there was
this breakthrough by a kristiano
culinaire modrus v langtang that showed
that so now in the case of undirected
graphs get em to the four thirds so this
was sort of the first sign that well
maybe undirected graphs are easier than
in the directed case and then so in this
work we get it down to basically nearly
blenders or em to the one book list of
epsilon and independently at nearly
exactly the same time Kellner the iraqi
and syd ferd also obtained over the same
ultimate running time would be a
slightly different algorithm so i'll
just mention that basically the both of
these results were obtained using
techniques that reduced in spilling
tangs paper for solving laplacian
systems and i think it be accurate to
say the philosophy for for both papers
is basically try to do for maximum flow
what spilling tang did for electrical
flow is you can view solving a laplacian
system as an algorithm for a certain
kind of flow algorithm that does
something different from maxillary
minimizes lt10 in 30 norm and so the
main difference between these two recent
works is basically so the klos algorithm
is the introduced a technique to get 1
plus epsilon approximate flow algorithms
from weaker approximate full of
algorithms and also in order to do that
they also had to give they also had to
present a new approximate flogger and
also that the approximate flogger than
they present did is oblivious so it's it
also has is an independent interest
because it gives an oblivious routing
scheme the differences in this work we
don't it's somewhat weaker requirement
we can get 1 plus epsilon approximate
flow algorithms from approximate
algorithms so the result is that you get
a simpler algorithm but uh the two
results kind of complement each other so
there's this interesting things in both
okay so let me give an outline so I'm
going to talk about so first just the
overall approach what the algorithm is
doing it involves so this notion of
almost routing and recursion and then
I'm going to talk about the key
ingredient that makes all this work
which is the notion of a cut
approximator and then i'll mention that
i'm going to talk about the general
framework in which this algorithm fits
which is basically demand and feasible
lagrangean relaxation and then and i'm
gonna give you the full algorithm
okay so so the main result is so given
so given the input which are the
capacities and the demands basically em
to the one plus a little o of one time
we can eat we can solve that that a the
approximate so that by criteria so we
can either find a flow that routes the
demands and such that the total flow on
an edge is less than mu plus epsilon to
the capacity or we find a cut whose
whose aggregate demand exceeds the
aggregate inbound capacity
okay so the plan for how this we're
going to prove this result in how the
algorithm works is so we're actually
going to do sort of we're going to look
at a different approximation we're going
to try to find a flow that exactly needs
that could be capacity constraints and
is sort of off on the demands we're
going to find flow that's so exactly
music capacity and sort of the demands
are not quite met but almost met and
once F is good enough where to say what
that means well then we're just going to
set ok well just at new demands to be
well whatever whatever our error is and
will set new capacities to be something
like epsilon I'm the old Capades
capacities I'm over curse if we can do
this then bull and everything works out
we'll get an algorithm that ultimately
rats base so we need to we need to say
why this works what does it mean to be
good enough how do we know if the
recursion will work and so on so that's
it okay and so when does the recursion
eventually stop so we'll see later that
basically once you do this log M times
so the remaining error is so tiny that
it's sort of trivial right so if you
imagine you do this login times each
time you're scaling down the capacities
by a constant factor do that you do this
a login times your new capacities are
like 1 over m your old capacities and
it's pretty pretty easy to get like a 1m
approximation of maximum flow so the
most important ingredient in this is
this notion of a cut approximator so so
okay so we have the song different i
want to say an alpha approximating cut
family so it's a collection of cuts such
that for any demands be I have this
inequality and so and so so what does
this mean so basically what it means is
if I want to know whether B is feasible
in an approximate sense this family will
immediately answer it just if I'm if I'm
only interested in this vision problem i
just want to know yes I can yes I can
route it with possibly with some
expansion of the
edge capacities or no I can't so in
particular if I'm given some set of
demands if I were to just check the cuts
in that set well certainly if I find cut
where the aggregate demand exceeds I
regatta capacity then I'm done i know
it's infeasible but on the other hand if
know if if according to just looking at
those cuts in that family it looks like
it would be feasible then the
approximate condition what it says is
that in fact the flow problem if i were
to scale up the capacities by alpha that
problem is feasible so this is going to
be a key ingredient to
ok and so why is this useful so I said
before we had to what we have to say is
really what do we mean by getting be b-
BF small enough well if i want to
recurse and i want that thing to work
out it means that whatever is left over
I better be able to route it in the
graph using at most epsilon C capacity
if I want to ultimately use one closet
since i already used one after every
curse i can use a most epsilon so we can
observe from this condition that if i
were to obtain a this residual are that
such that for all the cuts in this
family the error was small in particular
let's say it was less than epsilon over
alpha well then I know exactly what I
want I know that are with so that the
the new flow problems demands are and
capacities epsilon C is feasible so this
this construction basically is matches
exactly what we want in order to make
this algorithm work
hey
okay so the main theorem the main
subroutine that uses is falling so let's
now let's just let's see be any
collection of guts not necessarily the
suggestion approximately the cut
approximating family which is any
collection so there's an algorithm
called call it almost route such that
given the input data and also given this
collection so it's an iterative
algorithm it's going to make some number
of considerations say with a gym and so
either okay it finds the cut that we
want or it's going to find a flow that
satisfies this relaxed smallness
condition so it's a flow that so that
satisfies the capacity is exactly and
the residual r equals B minus BF
satisfies this relaxed condition net so
on any cut in the family are in the
congestion is less than delta and so in
order to get this less than delta you
basically need log size of CEO / delta
squared iterations each iteration
requires basically linear time plus
checking all the cuts in c so if you
have so if you had a family of cuts that
was nearly linear in size and it had
some kind of structure that you could
check all of the cuts quickly you'd get
under linear time algorithm
ok so now they need the important work
comes ok so he's take this theorem and
now we're going to sew that theorem
hopes for any family of cuts and now
let's just use that theorem with our
approximating family so so let's say we
have some approximate family and I'll
say it doesn't be linear size otherwise
useless rackety a linear time algorithm
I'm going to replace the log size of C
with log M ok and let's take that Delta
to be say so we're going to remember we
have so the residual is going to respect
capacities with in fact too thin factor
Delta so if we now set Delta to be like
epsilon over 3 a that three is just a
little thing to help us out I will see
why so then so after so if you apply the
previous theorem we get after basically
alpha squared over epsilon squared log n
iterations we're either going to get all
the cut that we want or we're going to
find a flow with that respects the
capacities and the residual satisfies
again just from the theorem the residual
on the set s is less than
missing
missing a shoe ases okay specially
epsilon over 38 x CS oh this ok but so
so the point is so from the so we have
that epsilon over three alpha that's in
the family and then the whole point of
the family is well once we have that
condition in the family now we can say
for all cuts RS is less than epsilon
over three times the capacity r is less
than epsilon over three times capacity
of ice so this means that whatever is
left over we know it can be routed with
with capacities epsilon over three so so
that means that now if we if we could
just recurse and once we recurse we
don't even need a really good
approximation if we could if we could
get it to within a factor of three when
we recurse then we have our epsilon
everywhere at so we'll use so we'll use
some of that so each time we recurse so
we're never going to which we need this
little factor of three just because if
we just had exactly epsilon you have to
solve it exactly so you know we just
give ourselves a little okay so at some
point seems like you have a kind of
Oracle that tells you for the very small
cuts are how do you then get a flow I
don't understand how we go back and
forth between just because I tell you
there's a small cut doesn't mean
anything so that's inside this algorithm
yeah I so it's ooh this is so we're
going to get to that enhance lost
hypothesis so is that also a flow or oh
okay so this is so this is somewhere
under the hood is something that will
generate flows or yes right so that's it
that's what this so that's what so the
theorem in the theorem might sort of
gift you take this theorem so this is
this is a this is algorithm that I'm
going to state later in the talk but
what it does so it says right here one
of the things that either gives you a
cut where it gives you a flow so the
flow was obtained by this sour than we
have access to an Oracle for both flows
and cut no no the this algorithm going
together but I'm at a high level there's
some kind of black box that returns this
stuff for you yes yes yes exactly and
then from that
trying to solution so once we have this
we're essentially done and just by the
by the recursion when I think he's
asking what the hypotheses what is
almost wrapped need and the point is
almost route only needs to do to
approximate the sizes of cuts it doesn't
ever almost drought produces flows
without ever being given any information
about flow is explicitly right I think
that's what you're going to it is that
almost route does all the flows what it
needs is just this the set of cut see
that's all i needs so you're explaining
how to go from some kind of cut oracle
to a flow exactly right but it's not a
general cutter or ball right it's like
this family is his family right but yeah
or some other kind of thing right
exactly so almost wrote is the almost
route is the algorithm that given this
cut Oracle is going to implement this
approximate floor
just to fresh memory said once we have
this or the thing in two hours later
we're done by recursion what exactly
does the recursion look like I missed
you probably said that earlier but it
was it you so we know then you get the
residuals okay so we each so we said bet
so right so this corollary was that
whatever is left over can be routed know
that if we were to take the capacities
and scale them down to epsilon over 3 we
could round okay so that means say if we
were to even just find a two
approximation for that flow we would
still have it with it means then then we
get two-thirds epsilon so maybe so once
we were cursed once we never care about
epsilon again we can just keep getting
constant factor approximation so that
little extra factor a third or so this
this sum is gonna is going to be a
geometrically increasing something is
going to be bounded by epsilon so I
think weather occurs i think the top
level is different from the levels that
are yeah exactly so well the top level
is different in that that's really the
only one where you care about this
epsilon after the top level do you get
the factor to which you approximate can
be a constant hey and also once you
after the top level you'll never find a
cut because you know if you're going to
find a cut you'll find at the top level
because once you recurse you have this
property that you know the problem that
your recur see on is flow feasible by
this property I mean the useful trick
for flow problems as you get residuals
but that's directed graph so somehow so
somewhere in here is a subtle point
about not ending up stuck with directed
graphs right so the residual is residual
demand so what I'm saying is you
basically just start so this is this is
a very pessimistic estimate I'm saying I
have some flow that I know all the the
flow on each edge is less than the
capacity it could be it could be much
less it could be exactly but then and
then I know that whatever's left over
can be routed with at most epsilon times
the capacity so certainly and if I were
to just take the sum of the flow i have
and that other flow that I know exists
that would certainly congest any edge by
at most 1 plus
so we're never we're not taking any
residual graph when we when we recurse
and we get a new flow problem we're
using the same undirected graph just
with the demand just with the capacity
is scale down by epsilon somehow it's
good enough that you can just work with
absolute values or the capacities rather
than working with residuals somewhere
under the hood doesn't happen right okay
so if you if your flow is equal to B
month is actually equal to the smallest
car then in fact after the most
difficult stuff because the other one
massive snow fluid which is again so if
your demand is tight in the sense that
it's actually equal to some cut okay so
once once you find the cut you you stop
immediately even if you find the flow
i'm saying if the flow is tight if you
demand is actually equal to the minimum
cut so bringing in demand is equal to
minimum cut so if you whatever the
demand is you need a FB equals behalf if
B equals minimum over all cuts CS
I don't follow
these oh you say if you compute a flow
and that flow is tight then you're
meaning it satisfies the command exactly
but that it that's never gonna happen
there's a cup of am I going what's the
size of a body the size the size of an
approximating fam is it the number of
sets in a family number says okay but
you're also assuming something like you
can compute the size of all these cuts
efficiently right yes right that's just
what I said in me yeah a generation
requires when your time cause checking
all the cuts
so so I just want to give some examples
so these cut approximator is they seem
extremely powerful in fact the first
time you see the definition it's like
how can it even exists so I want to just
give a few examples so at least you'll
before I get to the algorithm you'll be
convinced these things they really exist
and so I want to look at the simplest
here's the simplest cut approximator and
and if you use this so if you if you had
a graph that was at large conductance I
would basically this would be the
algorithm that you would want to use it
it would be extremely simple so we'll
get you it but okay so let's say we have
a graph that has large conductance so
what that means is that for every cut s
the total capacity of edges crossing
that cut is at least fee times the
minimum so over the smaller of the two
sets of basically the total number of
edges just their incident with that yes
so if i define say the volume of a set
is just this the total capacity of all
edges not leaving that set but just the
total capacity of edges incident with
that set then graph has conductance
really means is the capacity of any cut
is at least three times the total
capacity of edges incident with the
smaller side
okay so in a graph with this property
then I'm going to claim that the family
just of singleton cuts so just the cuts
where you just look at a single cut off
a single vertex is n of them there's
single vertex cuts that's a fee inverse
approximator why well okay so let's
suppose that we have some cut s where
the aggregate capacity exceed the
aggregate demand exceeds the aggregate
capacity and without loss of generality
we can assume that V of S is the smaller
side because note that so since the
total demand has to sum to zero this is
forgot to mention that defeating but
this is only or clearly you're only
going to find a flow if your neck
overall the sum over all vertices of the
demands should equal 0 because flow is
conservative I can't just get stuff from
nowhere so that means that in particular
the aggregate demand into s is minus the
aggregate demand it to V minus s so the
absolute value of the aggregate demand
on both sides of any cut are the same so
right so if I if I have this condition
so I'm going to just assume that s is
the smaller side because otherwise i
would just swap S&B my says okay well
then so I just know I know that then
that if I were just look at the sum of
the absolute values of the demands
that's certainly bigger than the
absolute value of the sum of the demands
which ought by so so this is bigger than
CS
by assumption which is bigger than CVS
which is fee some oversee on so this see
that so remember I use that notation
sees the best to be the capacity of
edges leaving the cuts so C of singleton
I is just the de group basically the
total capacity of edges incident with
high or the weighted degree of I right
so then if this holds then well some I
must have bhai bigger than visa
so in a graphic large conductance all
you need to do is check the singleton
cuts and that will that gives you a fee
anniversary right in other words take
any set of demands that that if you were
to just look at the singleton cuts you
know so the aggregate submit the
aggregate demand into any vertex is no
more than the total capacity of enters
into that vertex if that's true in a
graph with conductance fee then the flow
problem where you scale up all the
capacities by phien verse must be
feasible they just make sure I shake so
and if you were running your algorithm
on this graph then you would need that
or would you have to recurse than on
graphs that were no longer high
conductance when you recurse you recurse
on the same graph right so because we
citroen or someone we recurse we scale
all the edges uniformly okay so just get
on the demands right yeah yes
so I'm just in a state some other one so
I gave this this one so another so I'm
not going to prove these but uh so
another example if you let t be a
maximum capacity spanning tree so that's
maximum listen a maximum weight spanning
tree with respect to the capacities you
just look at now the single edge cuts
you cut a single edged out of that tree
that gives you a factor M approximator
intuitively the reason is because well
any if you look at any cut in the
original graph it's bigger than and you
look at the the capacity of that cut in
the tree it's bigger by at most a factor
of n so for a 2d grid if you were to
look at
family of cuts so look at the single
vertex cuts but then I also look at say
two by two sub grids and I'll look at
say four by four sub grids so basically
look at all the power of two sub brids
excuse you like a higher Google
decomposition this gives you a log to
the Oval one approximate
ah 11 actually I I don't know that's why
photo I think it's one would exercise
all right okay so um so another real I
do to her racket so for any graph
there's a similar kind of hierarchical
decomposition that gives a log n
approximator and it can be found in the
whole time so then but if you want a
linear time algorithm that's not quite
good enough so the thing we actually
need to use in our algorithm is this
result of modhri that's is for any graph
there's a set of n to the 1 plus little
over one cuts that yields an end to the
rule o of 1 approximator and it can be
found in nearly linear time and so the
main result so you actually get our
algorithm by using my breezers
approximator and then we just need to do
some minor data structures work to show
that we can check all the cuts quickly
notice that in the case where you have
one of these hierarchical hierarchical Z
compositions it's very easy to see that
you can check the capacity of all the
cuts quickly just by doing it's
basically a tree fixing the top one is
not hierarchical right so they can
direct one is hierarchical 00 the
laundry's is not hierarchical oh it's
probably like it's probably on its I'm
bug eyes are so accurate record several
the new first one is is hierarchical as
laura is a boy though it's nothing
though ah since the one the like the one
that you get an exponential time is log
is that
the Ricky 081 with a bunch o ok sorry
the one in it the one in this work is
the one in this road is not and then
exchequer ball or not yeah that one's
chicka Bow but the total size is fairly
big okay so okay so now okay good so I
told you about basically the basic idea
we're going to do the almost routing and
the recursion I told you about caught
approximator 'he's so okay so now i'm
just going to say okay what are these
demand and feasible lagrangean
relaxation and we'll get to the
algorithm and so okay so let's talk more
about this matrix B so let's remember
that if we had flow then be F sub high
is the net access into eyes so we can
think of B is basically like a discrete
divergence operator actually negative B
is the discrete version okay on the
other hand what does be transposed so if
if I have some function p i define on
the vertices V transpose P on an edge is
basically the difference between the
difference over that edge so it's like a
discrete derivative operator so figure I
want to consid to consider the case
where I want to say p I is a collection
of prices and I want to imagine that
vertex I announces he's willing to buy
or sell an item whatever whatever it is
that we're transporting in this network
for P I let me give an economic
interpretation of what these allergens
are doing
so suppose that in response to the
vertices announcing these prices the
network were to decide to buy some fe
units from i transport it's a J and then
sell to j the total profit will just be
to the sum over all edges of the amount
that's transported times the price
difference so when it was due and at the
point is that's when you see some form
like this p transpose BF what with that
is that quantity is is the total profit
for transporting according to F with
prices p so if you were if if such
prices p were declared the best thing
you could possibly do will just be for
each edge to say look at look at the the
two endpoints buy from which full
capacity from which were one is cheaper
transport that full capacity across and
then sell to the larger one and that
would earn a total profit of somewhere
all edges of the capacity times the
absolute value the other hand if the
if the network had actually ratedbe
instead the total profit would be just
this sum over all I PIB I so we can
observe that if for some prices it were
the case that well the total profit that
could be achieved by routing be was
larger than the profit the largest
profit that D that the graph that the
network was able to obtain then well
this must tell us that if the that be
must be infeasible and you do that's the
case you can show again it's fairly
simple exercise that one of the well so
first this immediately just by desperate
definition p is basically a hyperplane
separating the set of flows bf equals B
from the set of flows that respect
capacities but you can also get a cut
from this just by if you look at some
sets of the form the set of all vertices
whose price is at least t for some tea
one of those one of those for this the
threshold cuts one of those cuts is
going to be is going to have the the
condition we're looking for so the way
it's okay so the way our algorithm is
going to work
is so visual garden relaxation I was
basically sometimes you can give it as
simulating the dynamics of a market that
would solve the problem so on each day
the vertices are going to announce their
exchange prices each edge is going to
respond greedily just by rat during
ejaculation before it's going to take
full capacity by from the from the
cheaper cell to the higher and earn
then the vertices in response are going
to use those flow results or in koderra
is actually just the there need to know
the actual flow they just need to know
how much they bought and sold they're
going to use those to update the prices
for tomorrow and they're going to do
what you would expect so in particular
if there's if there's vertices where the
demand was not quite met they're going
to raise the prices there and if there's
vertices that were oversupplied they're
going to lower the prices there in fact
we'll see you the algorithm if i take
that singleton cut as my as my
approximate of family it literally the
prices are just going to be completely
local just dependent on weather demand
was met or not met just at that vertex
and so the idea behind this is well so
hopefully if we sort of dynamically
adjust our prices in a reasonable way we
should be able to show something like
the average flow so if we take some over
us if we look at just some overall days
so this is a flow that T times too big
so if we just taken me average by T this
should converge towards B or
alternatively some days prices will
proven infeasible so this is the basic
the basic flavor of this is an entire
this is a huge business basically a
framework a huge family of algorithms so
you have to specify the the method for
updating the prices so for any method of
updating crisis you get an algorithm
ok
so on day T let's let R be the residual
of the total flow seems so far so
basically the algorithm is going to try
to do is going to try to minimize some
function V of R it's going to try to
keep this dysfunctional and the prices
are basically going to be just the
gradient of V of R so this we need so
the way it's going to price a vertex is
the vertex is going to price its
commodity according to the marginal cost
with respect to this function sigh of
additional minutes entering
and the choice so that therefore the
choice of this function sigh interment
the price updates and that determines
the entire out so if I once once I state
a bright so if I just pick a function
sigh then the algorithm that I said
before so you use the gradient of the
prices and you run the algorithm I said
before and that's a complete oh so we
just need to say well how do we pick
sigh okay well so remember what we were
trying to do so what we wanted is we
wanted to minimize this
so so sidebar should be a smooth
approximation of the maximum over all
sets there should be RS / CS right so
that's what I that's what I really want
to what I want to minimize right my goal
is to ultimately find a residual such
that the maximum over all sets of the
residual / the capacity is small so
there's various things you could use you
could use different functions I'll just
I'll just pick a particular a few so
this is like an infinity norm so in
particular if you take a cue norm for Q
like log n great ah you know the key
norm crudely approximates infinity norm
and it's differentiable so the final
algorithm men is just going to be
exactly so then that so it's gonna be
the algorithm i said before using this
has the siphon so and then we can
basically interpret what's actually
going on is so if we look at so where do
these derivatives come from so on a
given day and basically say each cut so
it looks according to what is the
residual so far what is the residual
error across that cut and based on that
residual error it's going to declare a
price per unit crossing that cut and
then from those prices per cut we're
going to say okay so to transport you
the cost of transporting from i to j is
just the sum over all cuts that you
cross of the the price for that cut
so what we do in the middle of trying to
figure out how to find a flow so this is
so this is the floor right so right so
just so weird of the flow quit this over
right so this is so this is where the
flow algorithm so the flow is going to
be this is average flow
so this is where right so this was where
the flow came from so we iterate visited
on each day we pick right we pick this
we just greedily pick this flow and in
fact it's sort of really stupid it just
it's going to send full capacity in one
direction or the other even if we're in
the algorithm do we use the demand ah
quick so with the demands were here so
are there was our is the difference
between the total flow I've routed so
far and how much and this is what I this
is what should have been rounded so far
if they actually respect the demands to
tease on day t right so it's been two
days so if they were after the network
router but we wanted the net flow would
route t times be right on each day they
would round be so r is the difference
which what we wanted difference between
what we wanted versus what they actually
routed Jesus Kaler
that's RT is yet Tuesday tea
there's a scalar for big to get some day
one not two number of iterations season
here on the teeth iteration two yet
capital T Sullinger yeah
oh and that's this version has a
constant step size is that correct
you're always yeah yeah can you scroll
back to where you just put in those the
function fee weight is up just a little
I think ah oh no wait somewhere you had
this P tilde s the price time oh that's
so this would that was the first me at
the generic framework and now we get the
specific algorithm we specify this
function and that gives us a concrete
algorithm in your paper right it's not
quite it's not quite the same but it's
it's it's essentially the same it a
little bit or something sorry she's the
iterative method a little bit slightly
yeah but is it does this actually have
any like implications or just imported
interest simpler subject so you said the
prices were going to be the gradient of
the potential function is that clear
that that's what Yeah Yeah right so the
gradient I should be that should be
known as I did it should be RS / CS to
the Q minus 1 okay definitely eat
bars / service that's RS / see us today
to the Q minus one yes okay then then is
the great in here write it right so in
particular right so what's go ahead it's
basically it's giving times it's putting
a lot but it basically all the the
prices are going to come from the most
congested cuts right this this by
raising that to do to this Q minus 1
this is a huge power basically the only
things that are going to contribute are
those cuts that are with it 22 the only
thing either going to contribute check
prices are those cuts that are like the
nearly max Mike ingestible one of those
things so music you're seizing power Q
torsional to log of the cup family
should there is it all other also some
hidden epsilon Xin they're like family
of epsilon R epsilon squared or
something no the number of eurasia know
the number of variations determines
ok
um so this this power to the queue is
similar to the softmax yeah exactly
sorry so it's in the paper I use the
soft matte if you soft max is like law
is this function you commonly see in
multiple of weights log e to the X right
this is like presentation to max and
this is also an approximation to max
that thank you today but if you use this
then you have because we care about the
sign right to be care for RS / CS is
very large very positive very negative
so this is for things that are positive
so you have to if you want yourself max
you after that you have to make it
something like log of some of the X I
plus you give the minus X I do something
like that you just use the fuse these
you aren't worried about that
and here for each cut giving each cut in
the cut in in the family right yeah
right so we're for each the function is
some overall causing the family of
justice function this is basically this
Q arm of
so in particular let's say we had a
graph that had large conductance then
write these these sets are just the
singleton cuts and then literally all
the algorithm is is it's just it's
keeping track of you know there's some
residual at that vertex and it's
basically just so it's just a naive
thing to do would be to just say oh on a
given aeration I'm just going to say
okay whichever her check if this vertex
k has more residual than vertex B i'm
going to move from A to B it's a little
naive what you really want to sort of
normalize by the capacities and so
actually what this is doing so instead
of just instead of just moving by which
it which everyone's residual is larger
it's moving by whichever ones residual
to the Q minus one over C to the q is
larger was it out like that no before
from flowing expanders mean it's a very
sort of elegant serve algorithm not that
I know sort of flooding yeah no not not
that i know i mean that's that's right i
think if that were not sure once you
have that and you have the ideas in
instrument hang you sort of have to have
the rest of it right this is really
because sir this is the this algorithm
service yeah this is I guess I would
sort of think of this as like just doing
gradient descent in a in a solve OLAP
law seein system using or or maybe using
a diagonal preconditioner just with just
as I say a diagonal preconditioner by
idea so it with the counter at all paper
involves like constructing oblivious
writings on expanders by using
electrical flows or something so would
that also do the same without also if
you have this manner to begin with I
think that would also give you a fast
learner the first manner is comparable
to this or know the truth so their
algorithm is going to take the same
amount of time no matter no matter what
Wade you're using it you have this
better cut family for expanders right
where you just use this in a row to see
the same and their algorithm is using
these oblivious routings instead of the
cut families right but they're producing
the boobies routings but involved
through schemes that involved recursive
partitioning and eventually they were
out expanders specifically just using
electrical flow and they explained her I
think very good but oh look if the graph
were it was an expander would
I'm not sure exactly I'm not sure if
it'll be it could be similar it's not
it's definitely not going to be exactly
the same right a few iterations of
electric flow versus flooding the
degrees I don't know which is faster if
you do it right I mean so I think I mean
survive if if you told me to write a
mass flow algorithm in five minutes I
would probably write that the one for
the expander you're a because it's
literally just flooding or moving
there's not quite but moving from for
more residual to less but if you
suitably adjust by capacity is
essentially just that kind of flying
home this apply multiplicative way to
the van der right works is what you said
yessir the mobile yes'm yeah that's what
this Libby's
yes
like there's Pat they didn't multi-party
flow with with these kinds of algorithms
and and you can do it because the pounds
are short you can either do it that way
just doing the perishing that no patra
ok yeah I guess the problem is the
conservation and the conservation gets
screwed in a regular graph because the
paths are too long and you multiply them
together too much but but here you don't
get long path so you only pay the log n
quadratic a manga you know paths in this
or not yeah I comparative I what I'm
saying the same thing as what you're
saying ok so what you're saying is that
if you just apply somehow if you just
buy multiplicative weights to all the
constraints which is which is such every
cut all the constraints are the single
edge cuts you do that in any graph we
need some legit I mean the single part
tax cuts yeah oh ho ok yes the whole
problem is the conservation of this
ranks and also forget within or multiple
is that all
but but here you're saying okay well
it's not such a big problem in an
expander because the ball bounces right
but you don't have a path argument
somehow you're using you're going
through the total congestion approximate
of course right yeah so the reason it
works in the expander is because well in
the expand so in the expander being if
your residual is small and every vertex
that means you're good to go on the
recursion because it's your residual and
you're if you're next the graph is an
expander the residual small n every
vertex with respect to the capacities
well then you can just record you know
that you can recur spy it by the design
a preserver
yeah that's it that's very much not true
right if you don't obey the concierge
exactly right so for it so yeah so free
for so I probably a nice example is if
you if you consider what would happen if
you try to use like a naive expander
algorithm on say like a path right so
yeah the conclusion so the expander
algorithm and says oh great after like 1
over epsilon squared iterations the
residual floats okay so sorry let's say
it's a path and I have say one demand
here minus 1 here and 0 everywhere in
the middle so the conclusion of the
theorem is that so after 1 over epsilon
squared iterations the residual on every
vertex is less than epsilon ok so is
that's easy if I just all I need to do
is move this push this one sort of
smooth it out over the first one over
epsilon of these and take as minus 1 and
smooth it out over the first one over
epsilon of these and then i'll have that
conclusion but in the case of a path
that concluding is completely useless
because just having residual epsilon on
all of you on your fat epsilon epsilon
epsilon for a bunch of bees and minus
epsilon minus epsilon that still doesn't
mean i can actually route it okay
so the difference is here we are out in
the song is actually taking a look at
every single cut along the way yeah Jojo
kiss away so our path is kind of used
because it's a tree so I guess the so I
so I said an example in the case of a
general in a graph you look at a maximal
spanning tree and you look at the single
edge cuts that gives the approximating
family so and that would be exactly so
the more natural thing is the grid so
the grid has a same the same kind of
problem if I said say I put a bunch of
sources up here and a bunch of sinks
down here if I try to use just the local
algorithm it's going to take root end
time for iteration basically for the
first routing algorithms these guys in
the middle are gonna do absolutely
nothing because they see no information
whereas on the other hand if I add now
these power of two cuts and I'd use that
as the approximating family then then
something right on the boundary edge is
okay so let's say there's a bunch of
sources over here there's a bunch of C's
over here so naively if I just look
locally these things in the middle would
never would never do anything but if I
use this power of two cuts in particular
a look at these cuts then these edges
are going to see oh because even though
there's no local demand there's a large
aggregate demand into this cut and
therefore the price for this cut is
going to be large and therefore this
that's going to contribute towards even
this even a vertex that's right here to
contribute towards price and therefore
even from the very first step these
edges are going to start pushing ross
that's
yes no please suck sure this week search
for this picture looking at this in
terms of prices so it's so basically
what you're saying that if a cut like if
you have a lot of demands are out over
the cut basically will effectively try
to do something like send stuff over
that cut now rather than waiting till
the flow gets there or like that's how
it's not local in some sense yeah right
I don't know what does it mean for
waiting for the flow to get there but
this is different from like the local
algorithm of over the you know though
it's grew up on the path again I guess
is that it you're saying that will
basically start putting flow on those
edges immediately because it sees that
those edges are like a cross cuts that
are right because there's a large
aggregates or one of those sets is in
particular this huge set and that set so
it's going to have a large price and
remember such of the price on a local
vertex is the sum over all sets
containing it of those set prices so
that's why you the information
propagates master and these prices are
some kind of gradient of yesterday so
look so the local vertex prices are just
exactly they're always just the gradient
of Phi with respect to R all right so if
I now puts I as this particular like
this Q norm then register view so if you
first just look at the function just
with respect to each s you get okay that
should do if you have the Q minus one
there right that's if you look at as a
function of residuals across cuts you
get that derivative just RS / CS to the
Q minus one and then when you transfer
that to the individual vertices you get
that extra 1 / CS factor and so then the
which is in the the
the derivative a partial derivative at
vertex I is just the sum over all sets
of the contribution of like that
derivative with respect to s basically
comes up to anyway in this particular
Israel there's nothing that actually
really looks like a gradient of the cost
of your actual current flow is that
correct yes I'll give you a right so
they did so that is a different there's
a difference yeah so there's different
right so that's one slight difference
return it in a paper so in the paper
there's writing or is it the same titles
of paper it's not quite exactly the
paper I also this like weird sort of
strange function that accounts for both
the error in the residual and the
congestion and so this is a little
simpler in fact you don't need to you
don't need to have any function for the
congestion you can just always enforce
capacity feasibility so is the only one
more stupid thing is there any kind of
scheme like does this come out as a
natural like the one new people are some
sort of version of gradient descent can
you get this as this iterative scheme
it's some type descent skiing right so
that the interpreter that's exactly what
the size so it's so you're not quite
descending so I guess in this
interpretation it's not really
descending it's sort of trying not to
increase too much but I mean this is
just from the fact that right we're them
this R is growing because we're adding
right so this R is it's not the average
it's not the average residual it's the
sum over all days so it's going to grow
we just don't want it to grow too fast
it's exactly it's exactly where it is
yeah so there's a sense in which you can
think of some local awaits does exactly
the same thing
Oh Richard new swords sorry I probably
missed this but is there a clear role
like you there's a specific point where
you say how you kick the flow from the
vertex prices yeah so that's just it's
always the greedy it's always the greedy
flower you always put see capacity unit
of flow in either direction it works I
mean it's not it's not the smartest
thing but it works I missing another
version of your paper it is well my
thesis and I'm writing a journal version
that has this nada but I've been
thinking a lot about it try to simplify
it so okay is there any way of saying
simply what properties you need of this
function side because you didn't really
give us the analysis interview know what
the analysis is frankly not very
interesting it's if you know if it's
just the same as multitude of weights
it's just Taylor expansion it's just I
mean so so the point is to bound
slippery so that the point is right by
it so bus and since I said the prices
are the negative gradient gradient by
the flow always choosing like doing this
greedy I'm making this greedy flow it's
basically taking the larger step against
the gradient subject you're respecting
the capacities
so so you're probably the gradients not
be too big so what you know so what you
need is so these basically the exact
condition is that the second derivative
so the gradient should not change too
much ah for on your step and what that
means is basically the the second
derivative should be bounded in the l1
norm or the dual norms sort of capacity
great well again you can you can just
you can use no go to blazes of black box
that's why I Adam Judy I'll even a
gradient thing it's just mostly good
what over good weights multiple ways is
gradient descent okay but the so if you
want I mean to like that's what I did at
fox but if you sure if you want to
present it in multiple two weights you
need to like to find a game where yeah
we're like where these instead of these
things being prices that probabilities
and it's like yep let's go down the
slide you don't see it almost really
it's a good the residual there you see
there is John daty that serves is all
times being minus any minuses son he
shows every day the residual is
something that sum is less than zero or
something ah on average no so okay so
that's it okay so that the add the
actual if you want to see the actual
statement is basically so we know okay
so basically this condition on so for
how am I gonna free world over time oh
that's okay all right well then I'll
just this lesson which they basically if
you want to look at the analysis
basically so remember we said that we if
we had B dot P bigger than some e of c
TI minus pj we stopped okay so basically
if this condition doesn't occur that
means that so the minus Gramps i dot e
minus BF
this is zero so the first order change
in psy is that is shrinking or or I mean
if this were to be exact or that's
staying the same so basically so what
that means is that psy is only going to
grow second order so in particular if
you take yes oh so it's the only so the
growth of psy only gets contributions
from the second order
ultimately allows you so you altima tlie
you can prove something like sigh okay
so Swift so if sigh or if i were to say
this is RS / CS q norm
then you get something like car is less
than equal to square root on JT this is
a sweet little screwed log n times t and
the point is that right so clearly if
the if it was infeasible sigh of our
would have to grow like T so if you get
this sub linear growth then when you
take the average flow the residual is
gonna
so you get this sub because the first
order a contribution to the growth is 0
or less than 0 that's what it basically
gives you the swinger it's exactly the
same as multiple wait so how to do the
analysis because it's not interesting
it's just Taylor's there anything
questions
thank you